F3: All right.
Let's get right into former President Donald
Trump's came out swinging interview yesterday.
Donald Trump gave a painfully deranged and
comically delusional interview with Fox News
propagandist Maria Bartiromo last night.
One of the top brown nosers of the right wing
media apparatus is Maria Bartiromo.
Among other things, Donald Trump claimed that
he, quote, came up with the coronavirus vaccine.
Take a look at this.
M2: You add the fact that I was the one and
this administration was the one that came
up with a vaccine which is going to save the
world, OK?
It's going to save we would be, I think, worse
than 1917, where 50 to 100 million people
died.
The vaccine is such a big thing when you add
it all up, I think will do very well in two
years.
And I think we're going to do very well in
four years.
F3: Trump still calling the 1918 flu pandemic,
the 1917 pandemic.
We still don't know why he's doing that, but
he continues to do that.
But more importantly, more more comically,
Donald Trump insisting that he came up with
the covid vaccine, that he said we didn't
really need to get out of a pandemic that
wasn't very serious, a vaccine he received
in private in January and kept secret until
it leaked about 10 days ago that he had received.
That's the vaccine he says he came up with
completely disconnected from reality.
And remember that this is the guy who asked
at the start of covid if the flu shot would
prevent coronavirus.
That's not a joke.
M3: Remember this, but the same vaccine could
not work.
You take a solid flu vaccine.
You don't think that would have an impact
or much of an impact on Corona?
M4: No, probably not.
Probably not.
F3: So that's why now you're also on the vaccine.
Trump recommends it, although he says freedoms
are still important.
So good.
I mean, he's recommending it.
I think that that's a good thing.
This has been a bigger issue over the last
few days.
Democrats and health officials saying Trump
should really tell his followers to get the
vaccine.
They are one of the most anti covid vaccine
groups.
And Trump was prompted on this issue and he
said, I do recommend it, but, you know, we've
got to pay attention to freedoms, to its president.
F5: I know that you received the vaccine.
Mrs. Trump also got the vaccine.
Would you recommend to our audience that they
get the vaccine then?
M2: I would I would recommend it and I would
recommend it to a lot of people that don't
want to get it.
And a lot of those people voted for me, frankly.
But, you know, again, we have our freedoms
and we have to live by that.
And I agree with that also.
F3: So, listen, I'm not even going to dig
into that.
Let's just leave it at.
Trump said he recommends it all the other
stuff we'll put aside.
It's good that he's recommending the vaccine
to his followers when the topic of the 2020
election came up.
And actually the topic of Georgia specifically
also came up.
Donald Trump is still repeating now almost,
what, almost five months, three or four and
a half, almost five months beyond the election,
Trump continues to repeat the same lies about
the election.
And at one point, he gets so worked up that
he actually hits buttons on his phone while
talking.
Extra bonus in this clip is Maria Bartiromo.
Trying to interrupt Trump multiple times may
be worried that Trump is starting to go dangerously
close to the type of claims that could put
Fox in legal jeopardy as we've seen them then
B and other right wing media when this type
of stuff is said.
This just a comedy of errors taking place
here.
M6: Most honest person.
It was it was a beautiful it was a beautiful
and perfect statement.
And The Washington Post saw that when they
heard it.
And I guess they were relying to the statement
without hearing what was said, but they were
relying on the statement made by people in
Georgia that run the elections.
It's a very terrible thing, a very, very terrible
thing for our country.
What took place on not only Georgia, what
took place in Pennsylvania, what took place
in Detroit, Michigan and Michigan, generally,
what took place in Wisconsin?
Mr. President, Arizona.
It is a disgrace.
It's a we're like a third world country.
F3: And then Donald Trump quite literally
bemoaning that the Supreme Court didn't overturn
the election results.
They weren't willing to do it.
M2: And our Supreme Court and our courts didn't
have the courage to overturn elections that
should have been overturned because you're
talking about decisive amounts, hundreds of
thousands and even millions of.
F3: And he talks about the Supreme Court overturning
an election like it would be a completely
reasonable and casual thing to do, which,
of course, it.
Donald Trump then says that he hopes Meghan
Markle does run for president and that that
would make him more likely to have a good
shot at winning he on the side of the queen,
apparently, and reminding us he's met the
queen and take on Megan Markle now saying
she meeting with Democrat operatives she may
want to run for president.
M6: Well, I hope that happens, because if
that happened, then I think I have an even
stronger feeling toward running.
I'm not a fan of hers, but I think that what
she talks about, the royal family and the
queen, I happen to think I know the queen.
As you know, I've met with the queen and I
think the queen is a tremendous person and
I am not a fan of Megan.
F3: Yeah.
So Trump is pro queen, anti Meghan Markle.
For those who are wondering, Trump then repeating
the lie, at least an unfounded claim, apparently
a lie that terrorists from the Middle East
are crossing the US Mexico border a they're
coming in.
M2: You take a look.
They're coming in from all foreign countries.
I see they're coming in now from Yemen.
They're coming in from the Middle East.
They're coming in from everywhere.
They're dropping them off and they're they're
pouring into our country.
F3: Now, we have an entire segment devoted
to the border and this topic.
So I'm just going to say there is no evidence
of what Trump is saying, but we'll dig into
that in more detail in a little bit.
And then Donald Trump still repeating the
lie that Barack Obama and Joe Biden did terribly
on the H1N1 virus years ago.
M2: Biden failed very badly with the H1N1,
with the as you know, the the he had a chance
to do something and they had a tremendous,
tremendous failure.
H1N1, it was a disaster.
F3: Now, the truth is that the H1N1 virus
was essentially the regular flu in terms of
its severity.
And once that was determined, it was why once
you had community spread and something that
you didn't really treat any differently than
flu testing was ramped down, they often like
to say they weren't testing H1N1.
Well, there was no reason to test once you
had community spread.
And the actual approval rating for Obama and
Biden on H1N1 was 67 percent.
So by Biden actually not failing and not unpopular
on that issue, everything a lie complete and
total.
And my question is, what do you think Trump
wants to gain from these interviews?
Is it merely that he still has this kind of
sycophantic, narcissistic desire for relevance
and publicity?
Is it that he considers these interviews to
be part of his goal of being kingmaker going
into 2022?
What is is he just bored?
What is his objective in doing these interviews?
I'd love to hear from you about that.